scp-001 is an o5's tail it makes sense
doesn't it after all regardless of the
exact nature of an scp-001 proposal
there are always certain things that
remain the same see if you can recall
them all well for starters
scp-001s are all about vital moments
perhaps like the prototype or the
foundation or the sheaf of papers or the
gate guardian they're about the very
origin of the scp foundation itself
perhaps like the oroboro cycle or when
daybreaks or the world gone beautiful
they're about apocalyptic style
destruction or perhaps the rebirth
perhaps like consensus reality or the
database they are rules or realizations
that changed everything maybe like the
scarlet king or the black moon or a
simple toy maker they're about the
sparking of great rivalries that truly
define the backbone of the foundation's
activities another vital element of
scp-001 is always secrecy and
classification they are the most
clandestine anomalies out there
generally hidden away below layer after
layer of encryption and security even
the database for scp-001 entries is
guarded by a memetic kill agent that'll
leave you stone dead on the ground if
you're below that magical level 5
clearance when you attempt to access it
no information is more carefully and
forcefully guarded than this and of
course another vital element of the
scp-008 entry is deception and trickery
it's inherent to the designation no
other number has multiple entirely
distinct anomalies many of which either
have no correlation with one another or
even actively contradict each other if
you ask some people they'll tell you
that there are multiple zero zero ones
because each is of equal importance in
etching the rich portrait of the
foundation's past present and future
some would tell you something very
different there's only one
scp-001 it's a shell game the rest are
all fakes to stop people from taking any
single entry too seriously and thus
forever avoiding the truth some still
would tell you that there is no scp-001
it's all just a complex web of lies
meant to keep the foundation's enemies
and allies in a state of pliable
ignorance if an intimate knowledge of
the scp foundation's past and inner
workings a commitment to secrecy at all
costs and a love of deception as a tool
for control all sound familiar it's
because they're the favorite toolkit of
a certain group we're all familiar with
the o5 council the very top brass of the
scp foundation it only makes sense that
if anyone knew the truth about the
fractured and strange
scp-001 it would be them the more
observant among you may have noticed a
certain emission from many popular
scp-001 entries we've name-dropped in
this video so far and it is no accident
that this particular
scp-001 entry is the only one straight
from the mouth of 05-1
the founder of the council himself it is
the factory it is a strange and sword
tale of violence horror and dark
bargains made with truly unknowable
forces it's a tale that tells us about
the initial creation and growth of the
foundation the event then nearly
destroyed it and an indication as to the
dark future possibly in store it's a
little bit of everything you can expect
from a good zero zero one proposal and
surely if this is the scp-001 entry that
the head of the council swears by then
it must be the definitive entry into the
zero zero one cannon right well not
quite because as you're about to find
out not even the o5 council itself can
really reach a consensus on the true
nature of the fascinating and much
feared factory but perhaps through
hearing every side of this particularly
dark story we can find the kernels of
truth hidden somewhere in the middle of
it all but of course
be warned as with all things when it
comes to the o5 council it's going to
get extremely weird but before we move
on to what the rest of the o5 council
have to say about the factory it would
be prudent to refresh our memory on
05-1's version of the story the version
that has been considered to be absolute
before we pour into the equally strange
stories of the other council members it
began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named james anderson
all the way back in 1835 when the united
states was still new and finding its
feet anderson was an engine of unchecked
ambition malice and most of all truly
boundless greed he wanted everything and
more and being a true businessman down
to the core he was willing to make
whatever deal he needed to make in order
to see himself become an even wealthier
man that's why like a lot of bored rich
people in his day he began dabbling in
the dark arts for fun and profit until
eventually he made contact with a
benefactor on the other side under these
instructions james anderson built the
factory a truly magnificent and terrible
feat of architecture and engineering for
the time a multi-level town-sized
complex that could produce everything
from food to weapons to toys to textiles
to precious metals and so much more
workers could find room and board at
this grand factory and pay for it with
their labor for the would-be workers of
an unsteady early america anderson
seemed like a saint people flocked from
all over the country to live and work in
the factory but once they were locked
behind the factory's doors they realized
that james anderson was no saint he was
as bad or worse than any devil he served
the inside of the factory was a
torturous nightmare where people were
regularly worked to death and then
ground into meat that was sold off all
across the country anderson kept a
brutal guard force to beat down anyone
resisting or not working hard enough
those who weren't worked to death or
executed by the guards for some petty
infraction could potentially have an
even worse fate in store for them being
dragged off and subjected to occult
experiments by anderson these people
wouldn't be killed but they would live
as humans no more anderson was able to
keep the factory and its nightmarish
activities running and under wraps for
decades all the way into the civil war
it was only when a beaten bloody starved
and traumatized worker managed to escape
and alert president ulysses s grant of
the mistreatment going on inside that
something was done about it this is
where 05-1 and a progenitor of the scp
foundation would get involved there was
a small but elite group of union
soldiers commissioned by president grant
to work behind the confederate lines
specializing in tackling the strange and
supernatural down south this group of
course was led by 05-1 considering some
of the reports of anomalous supernatural
activity going on behind the closed
doors of the anderson factory grant knew
that these would be the men to send on
this vital mission and president grant's
faith in these men was rewarded though
it wasn't an easy fight they were able
to infiltrate and defeat the forces of
the factory they fought their way
through anderson's sadistic guards
through his menagerie of terrifying
homemade monsters and eventually they
got to anderson himself they were so
appalled by the horrors they'd seen
inside the factory they couldn't stop
themselves from torturing anderson to
death and dismembering his corpse they
freed the trapped workers and rooted out
whatever remained of anderson's forces
within the building however this is
where they made their first pivotal
decision rather than simply destroying
the sword place and leaving it as rubble
they instead decided to utilize it and
the many anomalous objects that it
produced this became the foundation of
the foundation over time their
organization grew and the o5 council was
formed they began spreading their
influence and capturing anomalies all
over this was however until they engaged
in a bloody war with the superior
military forces of the fae despite their
augmented weaponry and tools from the
factory when the fae performed an
all-out assault against them they were
decimated in his greatest shame 05-1
fled the battlefield into the bowels of
the factory as his friends and allies
were slaughtered by the fae behind him
eventually after locking himself in a
room with an ornate door he encountered
the true demonic heart of the factory
using anderson's dismembered corpse as a
mouthpiece 05-1 struck a terrible deal
with the factory they wiped out the fey
entirely and reversed all the damage
they had done the scp foundation grew
beyond the factory and eventually
covered it in rubble out of shame but
the factory wasn't done it is still very
much alive and furious at being betrayed
it will keep producing deadly anomalous
objects and creatures and releasing them
out into the world until the foundation
pays what it owes in full and the
occasional sacrifice d-class researcher
and guard won't cut it forever or at
least that's how o5-1 tells it it's a
chilling story but can it really be
called a complete one we wanted to find
out for ourselves which is why we asked
every other member of the o5 council to
tell their side of the factory's tale
these are 12 tales about a factory o5-2
upon being asked went white as a sheet
he cleared his throat and made the
admission that in truth the factory came
back with him as it turns out o5-2 was a
time traveler from the future back in
his native time an alternate timeline of
the present he was a mere researcher
until an accident led him to being
completely unmoored from time he was
thrown all over the temporal landscape
he saw civilizations rise and fall he
took the time to hang out with jesus he
was a pretty chill guy and ultimately he
decided the best way to use his bizarre
new condition was to help better the
future with his knowledge one piece of
technology he brought back was a hyper
advanced piece of technology known as a
nano factory which as the name suggests
is a machine that uses nanobots to
construct pretty much anything like the
ultimate futuristic 3d printer it
resulted in the creation of a huge
number of futuristic items that helped
the scp foundation along in their
mission to secure contain and protect
including amnestics however what 05-2
didn't realize was that a rogue ai was
also nested in the nano factory and the
ais soon went berserk as a result the
nano factory became the factory
producing dangerous anomalies with
reckless abandon to the detriment to
both the scp foundation and the world at
large on the whole it was somewhat of a
mixed bag 05-3 seemed a little spaced
out about even being asked he claimed
that he was there to witness the very
birth of the factory but it didn't
happen in reality as we know it it
happened in cyberspace he and his
colleagues were very interested in the
matrix-esque journey of downloading
their minds into computers back in the
day both for practical reasons and to
play extremely immersive games of doom
however one day something fundamentally
changed a new consciousness was born in
then soviet russia 05-3 and two of his
companions all operating in cyberspace
went to go check it out along with a few
helpful ai constructs eventually they
discovered it an ever-expanding data
packet that would transform into a
powerful artificial consciousness known
as the factory with mysterious motives
and seemingly malicious intent something
it more than proved when it erased the
mind of one of o5-3's companions killing
him since this incident the factory has
only gotten more powerful its modus
operandi is affecting machines in the
real world and causing them to produce
anomalous items which then become the
scp foundation's latest problems to deal
with 05-4 seemed both twitchy and
indignant when the topic was brought up
they lamented the fact that the
foundation hadn't put more research into
the factory and how to stop it because
technically it is their most dangerous
and mysterious enemy group of interest
05-4 explained it as follows the fbi
unusual incidence unit is a joke are we
cool yet is just a bunch of pretentious
privileged rich kids marshall carter and
dark limited only care about money and
thus can be bought off the global occult
coalition often helps them take care of
more challenging anomalies the church of
the broken god and the sarcists are
often too busy waging petty religious
wars against each other to do real
meaningful damage to the scp foundation
prometheus labs had already fallen and
dr wondertainment wouldn't thrive
forever the factory however was a truly
unknown quantity it's just out there
somewhere pumping out anomalies that
soon become everyone else's very
dangerous problem 05-4 personally
resented that the foundation and their
fellow council members don't see this
and allocate more resources to the cause
because someday soon
it might really come back to bite them
as these things often do o5-5 was
considerably bitter as in they denied
that the factory ever even existed
claiming that the scp foundation made it
up to cover up a bunch of anomalies that
they themselves had created and then
told us to
f off if you know what i mean
some people get so hostile when you just
want simple answers next came the tale
of 05-6 which came in the form of a
world war ii espionage anecdote of
course this was also during the height
of the seventh occult war and hitler
assisted by the fuel society and obscure
corpse was trying to get his greasy
little hands on as many anomalies as
possible in hopes of turning the tide of
the war in his favor
05-6 was working undercover behind enemy
lines disguised as an ss officer as he
slowly helped dismantle hitler's
anomalous offensive from within he'd
heard whisperings of the nazis
developing a weapon unlike any other a
factory that would produce anomalies for
them on demand and give them the
supernatural edge 05-6 didn't believe it
at first until he was attacked by a
group of vicious living punch and judy
dolls created by the factory he nearly
managed to survive the ambush but seemed
disturbed in recounting the fact that
when he destroyed the dolls they bled
profusely eventually the leads he was
following led him to a ruin at the base
of zug swootz inside he discovered the
ruin was hollow and filled with floating
stone orbs producing energy that allowed
the teal society researchers to produce
more anomalies 05-6 was able to destroy
this anomaly factory but he took a
souvenir scp-627
a little stone ball that rolls around on
the ground when it comes into contact
with people 05-7 admitted somewhat
sheepishly that while there was
technically no real physical factory
factory product anomalies are real and
they're all his fault he purchased a
bunch of random items from walmart and
printed a fake logo for the factory on
the back his plan was to give these
totally innocent objects to junior
researchers both to mess with them for
fun and to test their critical thinking
skills however it turned out that simply
placing this logo onto an item resulted
in becoming an anomalous item admittedly
it was rough for 05-7 to have to follow
the cool story about fighting magic
nazis
05-8 made the far more exciting claim
that the factory is actually all the way
up on the moon back when the scp
foundation were first founding moon base
alpha they discovered that some ancient
and unknown civilization had already
built a covert base under the surface it
was a storehouse of anomalous alien
technology the first 13 people to enter
were immediately vaporized by the laser
defense system but the fourth to enter
was given an even worse fate he was
pulled into the machine and fused with
it at which point the factory was truly
activated it began to produce anomalies
and transport them to random locations
all across the globe and it's been a
problem ever since when we spoke to o5-9
on the matter with a steely look in his
eye he simply muttered the word atlantis
no further comments were made on the
matter 05-10 explained that the factory
was a single man a truly ancient and
brilliant anomalous craftsman that they
found in a mountain temple in tibet it
was taken by the foundation and
contained but given far more high-tech
tools to work his magic so they could
keep reaping the anomalous fruits of his
labors however the craftsman was
appropriately crafty and managed to
produce a duplicate of himself to
distract the foundation while he made an
escape he's still out there to this day
making more anomalies a one-man factory
05-11 claimed that the factory was alien
in origin but it wasn't on the moon it
was the true explanation for the iconic
1947 roswell new mexico ufo incident a
flying saucer descended and offered
05-11 who was the commander of the
response team at the time the most
wonderful things this saucer became the
factory but humanity and 05-11 were
deceived it wasn't long before this
extraterrestrial factory was producing
countless deadly anomalous nightmares
the world over with nothing we could do
about it 05-12 said that the factory is
a mess it's a remnant of the
foundation's attempt to erase the
supernatural from human belief
foundation researchers claim that due to
the inherent power in human belief the
belief in the supernatural gave it power
and phasing humanity as a whole out of
this belief was a major factor in making
sure things weren't much worse than they
are today however some hardy things slip
through the cracks and because reality
has a strange sense of humor these
things are marked with the logo of the
factory to round things off we have a
bonus take from the mysterious 05-13
who is instrumental in helping us put
the rest of this video together he
claims that he created the factory and
that it acts as a kind of countermeasure
against inter-dimensional invaders while
it may seem like the factory is creating
anomalies it's actually intercepting
them and making them safer some
anomalies that seem to come from the
factory may be dangerous but if o5-13 is
to be believed then they'd be a hell of
a lot more dangerous if the factory
wasn't here and there you have it folks
the story of the factory from every
possible angle even though it feels like
each angle is facing in an entirely
different direction in the words of
oprah winfrey so what is the truth is
there a nugget of reality beneath all of
the fallacy or do you think the o5
council was trolling all of us for even
daring to ask we leave that question to
you dear viewers let us know which
theory you believe down in the comments
below now go check out children of
scp-001 the scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son and scp-001 the
oroboro cycle the full epic story
explained for more tales of the
frightening mysterious and always
fascinating anomaly scp-001